i mean i did an event this was a like
when i first
got to cnn and did united shades there
was like a hollywood reporter
roundtable reality television roundtable
and this was i mean this was years ago
and you'll know how years ago
i was they they called me to do it and
they said that like
uh tony bourdain was going to be there
and i was like oh well i'll definitely
do it because i hadn't met him yet i had
the [ __ ]
right here and i was like great i get to
hang out with tony i haven't met him and
i've been wanting and i've been a fan of
his since before i had the show
and then i got there and it was a bunch
of other
uh reality television people and i got
there and
tony is standing on the corner talking
to the publicist from
from cnn and she's this little tiny lady
and he's this tall guy and she's like
pointing in his face like
like clearly like like sort of like like
brown be like looking like a teacher
talking to a student who just failed and
i expected more of you
and he just sort of looks like ah and
then i walk up like hey man he's like
yeah
i gotta go and he leaves and then i walk
in
and he just he just does it so he
doesn't do the event and i walk in and
she's like
he he had some previously scheduled
business and i'm like i can tell a lie
when i heard
and then i walk into where we're
recording the interview and i walk past
like the green rooms and has everybody's
name on a piece of paper
and one of them says kris kardashian and
i was like oh
[ __ ] because i knew he he like hated the
kardashians and i'm like he left because
kris kardashian because i didn't know
kris kardashian was gonna be there
either
and i think she got booked at the last
minute and he's like i can't sit and i
found out he was like i can't sit at a
table with a member of the kardashian
family
wow right and he just walked out it was
bounced and i thought it was one of the
greatest
things of all time even now wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
greatest things of all time all the time
my list of greatest things
i want to hear the other greatest things
of all time
wow so these beat the discovery of fire
as a way to
uh okay i wasn't there for that so maybe
it
wasn't
i saw andy bourdain leave a seat in
public
because he didn't want to stomach a kim
card uh kris kardashian i saw that
happen and i was like that dude
is knows who he is and i wish i had that
much integrity anyway
i'm gonna go in there and talk to kris
kardashian
and at the end of this event it was like
me rupaul
her some other people uh leah remny
uh kris kardashian gave everybody gift
bags
i was like like handed everybody like
and like was like wait and she's just
invited
i mean she's not hosting the thing she's
not she's just she just she really just
showed us all up to go you didn't bring
a gift bag
wow i brought gift bags and she had gift
bags of like whatever
kylie's new lip kit was
oh well wait that's that's not really a
gift pack
i mean it
my father has a brick business here's a
brick
it's got my thought the name of my
father's brick business on it
i still had not ever seen anybody hand
out random gift bags that weren't a
kid's birthday party
or a wedding so i was pretty impressed
at the time and she was like give this
to your wife and i was like how does she
know i have a wife like they have like
a dossier oh my god